you begin this morning with the
aftermath of the terror attack at a
crowded mosque in Egypt that left at
least 305 worshippers dead and 128
injured friday's assault was in the
northern part of the troubled Sinai
Peninsula so far no group has claimed
responsibility for the attack Charlie
d'Agata is following developments from
our London Bureau and he has the latest
charlie good morning good morning
Egypt's president vowed to respond to
the massacre with an iron fist and
within hours jets were scrambled
launching air strikes targeting the
militants behind the worst terrorist
attack in that country's recent history
the Egyptian military released video
this morning claiming to show fighter
jets targeting vehicles used in
yesterday's attack that they said killed
suspected militants inside and zeroing
in on hideouts while outside the
hospital exhausted medics loaded
ambulances with more victims they simply
were not able to save the blood-stained
walls inside the mosque tell of the
horror that unfolded when as many as 30
armed militants set off a bomb during
Friday prayers and gunned down as many
worshippers as they could as they tried
to escape even opening fire on emergency
vehicles trying to tend to the wounded
Egyptian president Abdel Fattah al-sisi
has vowed to respond with brutal force
to those behind the attack for years the
Sinai Peninsula has been a fertile
ground for Islamic extremists like Isis
despite repeated government attempts to
root them out in the past the militant
group has targeted Egyptian soldiers and
security forces an Isis in the Sinai
also claimed responsibility for twin
bombings on Christian churches that left
45 dead and killing a busload of
Christian pilgrims earlier this year but
yesterday's attack was the first-ever
large-scale assault on a mosque
worshipers there practiced the Sufi
branch of Islam which Isis has branded
as blasphemous a place where they
gathered for peace and sanctuary
yesterday provided neither one some have
noted that the attack took place in a
small tight-knit village and that stem
during death toll amounts to about 10%
of the population Alex Charlie d'Agata
in London thanks charlie